so I had a great time at Boston
University last night next stop will be
Baylor University which I was told last
night that you know Boston University
Baylor University the real BU is Boston
they were very clear about that so I'll
be there next Tuesday and I suspect that
that will not be quite as easygoing as
it was here in Boston which was which
was nice interesting enough I come up
here to Boston to a liberal area secular
school and there's no problem at all you
know there's it sits perfectly respect
there were some people that showed up at
the talk and disagreed but we had a
respectful exchange but then going to
Texas to a Christian school that's where
there's apparently going to be some
problems anyway that's not really the
point the the point is what I wanted to
mention from last night is I went out to
eat with some of the students afterwards
and they were all very nice and I
enjoyed it but at this restaurant on the
menu in the taco section there was a
little note that said that the the corn
tortillas are gluten aware not
gluten-free they're gluten aware corn
tortillas so I don't know what that
means exactly does that mean that the
tortillas will like give you a speech
about gluten to meant to raise awareness
of or is the chef back there lecturing
the tortillas about gluten to make them
aware of it I don't know I tried to ask
the waitress but she it wasn't it wasn't
much help so that's and maybe it's just
a Boston thing I have no idea so I want
to touch on a number of topics here and
then leave time for for a bunch of
emails at the end on a Friday so first
Tucker Carlson is taking some heat today
because he had the audacity the gall to
suggest that immigrants should
assimilate into our country and he's
been accused of white nationalism for
making this case in his monologue on a
show last night I'll play you a clip but
just warning if you've got little kids
in the room maybe uh sure them out
because this is pretty disturbing stuff
watch this
who should we prefer what's the ideal
level of education an immigrant to this
country should
big business doesn't want you to ask
this question they like they're
immigrants low-skilled and cheap Acacio
cortez does too but what happens when
technology kills their jobs and it will
all the major Democrats running for
president take money from the technology
barons many of them support self-driving
cars so what do you do with hundreds of
thousands of unemployed immigrant cab
drivers do they all go on welfare and
speaking of what sort of government
services are immigrants entitled to
exactly democrats promised universal
health care the immigrants get that too
who pays for it how many immigrants can
our systems support do we have enough
doctors and nurses and hospitals to
treat the number of immigrants we want
to admit same question for schools the
real answer is of course nobody knows
because as of today we have no idea how
many immigrants live illegally in the
United States shouldn't we find out
before we make more plans and once we do
find out what do we do with them who
gets deported anyone or do all of them
get to stay what if the real number of
people living here illegally is north of
25 million and that's entirely possible
that's bigger than the population of 48
out of 50 states it's enough to change
this country completely and forever do
all of them get citizenship and voting
rights
what about gun rights and do they
immediately start paying into the
reparations for slavery fund that
Democrats are now promoting how will you
explain that to them can we watch that
conversation and finally what about
America's ideals Democrats are always
talking about values when the subject of
immigration comes up they quote from the
poem on the Statue of Liberty and tell
you about their grandparents well
previous waves immigrant immigrants were
asked to buy into this country's most
basic ideals religious pluralism free
speech political freedom equality under
the law our schools made them war in
English and tried to instill patriotism
we called it assimilation we thought it
was critical to our social cohesion are
we still for that do we still think we
have values to impart oh dear God what
what what a horrifying oh wait no no no
actually that's not horrified it that
actually makes perfect sense and it's
it's totally reasonable and the bit
about the bit about immigrants
contributing to reparations was pretty
it was pretty good because I suspect
that liberals would say that immigrants
should not pay into rap
operations but if they don't then what
about people who immigrated here ten
years ago and if they don't have to
contribute then what about people whose
parents immigrated here and if they
don't have to contribute what about if
your grandparents or whatever about your
great-grandparents did it seems like if
the if the if the mature is that well no
of course an immigrant wouldn't pay in
because they weren't even in this
country when when any of this stuff was
happening well yeah I agree but first of
all none of us were in this country when
slavery was happening and second of all
most of us our families weren't even
here so it seems like if they're off the
hook that we all should be but the
greater point is about it's about
assimilation which know is not a white
nationalist conspiracy in fact it may
surprise some leftists to learn that you
know there are 195 countries in the
world most of them are not white and the
thing is if you immigrate to any of
those non-white countries you will be
expected to assimilate this is this is
the case in any country white or
non-white so assimilation is not a code
word for white nationalism it's got
nothing to do with whiteness at all
leftist pretend not to understand this
this basic idea that assimilation
is not about racism it's about it's
about social cohesion it's about
maintaining an actual country and it
really is that simple
you see some of us want in actual
country we want a country not just a
geographic area where a bunch of us
happen to live we want an actual country
a real live country meaning a place with
a shared culture a shared language
shared values shared traditions all of
that that's what we want that's what a
country is and we Americans are entitled
to that yes I don't use the word very
often but we are entitled to that we are
entitled to live in a country that is a
country one of the most basic rights
that we have as Americans is America
itself we have a right to that and when
I say we have a right to that what I
really mean is that our leaders our
politicians have a responsibility to
protect that to protect our national
identity
and to protect the social cohesion you
know it's often said that we are a
nation of immigrants and that's true in
a sense but the difference is that
immigrants in the early days of America
came here and they helped to form our
cultural identity they helped to build
our country okay
immigrants today though it's a very
different situation they are not
building the country because it's
already built and oftentimes they're not
even interested in being part of our
culture they want to come here and do
their own thing they want to have their
own little country unto itself their own
language their own culture values
history traditions everything so rather
than building a country they are balkan
izing the country which is an entirely
different thing it's actually the
opposite I've made this point before
about the advantage of marrying young
and I think there's kind of a parallel
here so the advantage of marrying when
you're like 20 years old or something
even though I did I married when I was
25 but even then that's pretty young by
today's standards the advantage of
marrying young is that you sort of get
in on the ground floor with your spouse
and you build a life together you start
from scratch together and you do all of
this together you form a common identity
rather easily because you you you you
know you enter each other's lives when
neither of you really have anything you
don't own anything you don't have
anything you don't have much of a life
of your own
and so you form that together but when
you marry late which plenty of people
marry late and have wonderful marriages
but there's a challenge and the
challenge is when you marry late you
already have your own life you have your
own identity your own house your own
finances your own car your own job your
own goals your own history maybe even
your own kids and so now you're trying
to combine these two separate identities
at that point and form one thing which
isn't impossible but it's harder well I
think a similar thing is happening with
immigrants right immigrants 200 years
ago well they're like marrying young
right because it's because they're
getting in on the ground floor when
when we were still sort of figuring out
what America is what it's all about
building it forming it immigrants today
though are different
that's like a late marriage they are
coming when everything is already formed
they've got their own thing going on
we've we've got this thing already
happening and so they come here and it's
already established and many times
they're coming here to take advantage of
the system that's already been built
rather than to contribute to it that
doesn't mean that we should prevent
everyone from coming but it does mean
that we need to focus all the more on
assimilation because we need to realize
that that there are there are already
going to be just naturally certain
challenges that we have to face with
immigration today as opposed to 200
years ago and then it makes it all the
more challenging when you when you
factor in all the illegal immigration
and the welfare systems that they could
take advantage of and everything else ok
so um this is this is kind of funny and
I want to read by the way I am a little
under the weather today so if my I feel
like my voice sounds like a dying
Buffalo or something and it's because of
it's because of that so I apologize that
so someone sent me an editorial from
their college newspaper this is from
Luther college and I love when people
send me crazy editorials from their
college newspapers and so I encourage
you to do that if you stumble across a
crazy editorial in your college
newspaper please send it to me I want to
do a regular segment and we'll call the
segment you know just brainstorming
we'll call it crazy editorials in
college newspapers and so if you ever if
you ever happen to cross one please send
it this is this was sent to me by a
concerned citizen of Luther college and
I will read it to you it's written by a
woman who's upset by the the the
goings-on at Legends which I guess
Legends is that the building on campus
where people go to work go to work out
and stuff like that and so the article
is titled an open letter to ever left
the seat up in legends the other day you
know this is gonna be good
it says I work out a lot when I'm
stressed
so naturally I was in legends almost
every day last week and upon spending a
lot of time there recently I have
discovered some of my new favorite
things about Luther's state-of-the-art
workout facility I just think it's great
how I can walk in there and be instantly
transported to a front-row seat at a
Country Music Festival because of how
loud the music is playing it's also so
cute when guys stare at me less than
three feet away while I'm finishing
using the machine and while we're on the
topic it's awesome when men don't clean
machines after they use them and by
great and cute and awesome I mean that
it's extremely problematic and it needs
to be addressed because this is not
about the toilet
it never was this is about the toxic
masculinity that plagues the legends for
Life Fitness Center and the fact that I
cannot work out on campus without
stepping into a reformed gentleman's
club and when you do things like bounce
around from machine to machine with
little disregard for others using it
shout and yell on the floor as your
friends lift weights or leave the toilet
seat up in a unisex bathroom the titular
event of this opinion piece you
perpetuate the stereotype of many
workout facilities that women are a
secondary thought when it comes to
athletics don't believe the history of
sexism that plagues athletics and Luther
specifically I encourage you to look
through the recent series of women in
motion and chips for countless examples
of how female student-athletes have been
historically marginalized by the
athletic department the last time I
identified as an athlete was my
sophomore year of high school as a
middle hitter for the junior varsity
volleyball team so you could say that
I'm more than a little removed from the
world of athletics so the fact that I
someone who only steps foot in regions a
few times a week for a quick workout can
pick up on the sexism in that building
is incredibly upsetting I could not even
imagine what it would be like for that
to be a more integral part of my life
there are small tangible things that
lutheran legends can do to change the
sexist workout culture maybe start with
a sign reminding everyone to put the
toilet seat down after they're done
using it it's great that both of those
bathrooms are unisex and I don't want
that to change but we need to start
treating them like the gender-neutral
spaces that they are could we also set a
limit to the noise level of teams when
they're lifting weights on the main
floor I understand that team camaraderie
is important but that does not mean that
the music should be turned up as loud as
possible and that loud yelling should
ensue every five seconds loud yelling
ensuing that's it
that's there's a lot of loud yelling how
did sues in my home because I have three
kids and so I understand that it is
completely disrespectful to everyone
else in the room there are some small
things that I believe would help but
there are also larger structural things
that need to change to my male allies do
not be a bystander I know this is hard
but your friends need to need you to
advocate on behalf of them when you
aren't when we aren't in the room
push your teammates to change the way
they talk about women think about the
implications of your actions when
working out to my fellow women
non-binary friends and everyone else who
may feel marginalized in Regent's or
legends please please do not be
complicit so my friend who left the
toilet seat up I hope you can now
understand how this one's seemingly
small act is so much more than that you
should not leave a mark of your
masculinity on a space like you're a dog
urinating marking its territory
especially when that's supposed to be a
gender-neutral and inclusive area be
better do better we're supposed to have
gender equality at Luther and 2019 so
let's all start acting like it
really I should have been wagging my
finger through the whole thing because
just you have just imagine the finger
wagging so there you go I love that that
phrasing there was this great you
leaving a mark of your masculinity on a
space well now you've just made me want
to leave the toilet seat up even more
because I I feel like I want to leave a
mark of my masculinity on a space in any
space that I'm in oh my lord
first of all the toilet seat thing I I
you know who who says I've never
understood what why is it that men
should put it down but what women
shouldn't maybe women after you're done
you should put the toilet seat up for us
have you ever thought about that stop
leaving marks of your femininity all
over the bathroom and and but really I
think when it comes down to it see when
I walk into a bathroom and I see that
the toilet seat is down but I want it to
be up I don't break down in tears and
say what is this doing down Oh No
Lord what am I supposed to do the toilet
seat is down help help
no I don't do that you see you see what
I do is I just I just I just lift it up
so I I just do that right so and it
takes like one and a half seconds it
really is all that's all it takes in
fact I want if you if you're watching
right now pull out a stopwatch okay pull
out a stopwatch I want you to time me
because I want to own it we're gonna do
it experiment here
okay so pull it out and then let's I'm
gonna mind putting a toilet seat down
and see how long it takes all right
so okay ready go how long did that take
me two seconds maybe one and a half in
fact I bet if you added up cumulative Li
all of the time that this woman has
spent putting toilet seats down in her
entire life
it would not add up to the amount of
time it took for her to write this
article complaining about it because it
really doesn't take any time at all and
really I know that you know if you're in
a public restroom you're not gonna use
your hands you're gonna use your foot so
it's gonna be more like you know like
you're raising your foot up but my lord
this is like a machine gun
nagging it was just one after another
one after and another thing I'm tired of
the loud music in this room too can you
imagine what this gals boyfriend must
have to cope with on a daily basis
honestly I I and I don't mean this as an
insult but I really really don't
understand how feminists ever managed to
find boyfriends or spouses I mean how
could a man tolerate this for even one
day can you imagine having to sit there
and listen to her complain about sexism
at the fitness center can you imagine
because yeah can you even imagine what
that would be like this is why I you
know my wife is not a feminist thank God
we would not have worked if she was a
feminist it's one of the first things I
asked when we sat down for dinner on her
first aid because if she had told me
she's a feminist I would have said all
right you know what I'm gonna leave I'll
let you pay because you're a strong
independent woman and let's just cut
this thing off now because this isn't
gonna work but actually I think the
first time I asked my wife if she's a
feminist she laughed she
laughs and then she launched into a
whole argument a whole rant about about
her problems with feminism and I said
okay this now this is yes this is marry
me now let's just get married now in
fact we just based on that I will let's
just cut out the rest of it let's just
get married I mean that almost literally
what happened I could propose to her
after like six months it's it's you know
this this woman says that men need to
hold each other accountable I agree and
so that's why I'm saying to other men
don't date feminists it's not worth it
don't do that to yourself and don't do
it to them either because they obviously
hate men so don't don't inflict yourself
on them and don't allow them to inflict
themselves on you all right so that was
good that was good fun though I
appreciated that one other thing before
we get to emails I said I was I was
speaking at Boston University last night
the talk was on abortion and I went
through and I tried to thoroughly
respond to what I consider to be the top
four pro-abortion arguments one you know
the first argument that unborn babies
aren't people to bodily autonomy three
rape and incest and then four that
people are going to get abortions anyway
so you might as well have a safe and
clean place for them to do it so that
doesn't end up in a back alley so I
responded to all those arguments I tried
to debunk them and I have to say credit
where credit is due to myself in this
case I did a great job
now there's another argument for
abortion that I consider to be so weak
that I didn't spend really any time at
all on it but it came up a lot in the
Q&A and then again at dinner not so much
because the people bringing it up were
themselves making the argument but
because they said they encounter this
argument a lot they wanted to know how
to deal with it and that is the argument
from socioeconomics the idea that we
need abortion because it helps the
economy and if you get rid of abortion
it would hurt the economy because now
you have more poor people and poor
mothers with babies that they that they
can't feed and so on so that's that's
the that's the argument the next time I
give a talk on this I guess I'll spend
more time on it even if I think the
argument is
it's apparently convincing to a lot of
people but I will address it here very
quickly so there are two basic responses
to the socio-economic argument for
abortion to the idea that it helps the
economy abortion helps the economy
number one so what it doesn't matter
it's irrelevant it is it is never
acceptable to justify murder for
economic reasons murder is never okay
for economic reasons the pro-life case
is that babies are human that all living
humans are people and that it is never
okay to intentionally directly kill an
innocent defenseless human being that's
our whole case that's all we're saying
it's very simple
and none of that is affected by the
economy does it doesn't change one way
or another depending on what's going on
with the economy doesn't make a
difference and so even if you could look
into a crystal ball and show me that
abolishing abortion would plunge our
country into poverty and destitution I
would still say without hesitation
absolutely let's do it
I'm ready because I would rather live in
a poor country that does not kill babies
than in a rich country that does and
throughout history it has always ended
in massive amounts of bloodshed one's
countries start to justify murder for
socio-economic reasons and we are not
the first ones to do it
slavery was was was justified on largely
socio-economic reasons on a largely
socio-economic basis it was not just
that the racist slave owners although of
course they were racist but it wasn't
just like on principle that they thought
that you know these black people deserve
to be enslaved you know they did have
that attitude but but more important to
them was it was about the money right
it's about the bottom
that's what it always comes down to for
4p especially evil people and they said
look slavery helps the economy you get
rid of slavery our entire economy is
gonna collapse not only do you collapse
our means of you know production but you
also then create all of these new mouths
to feed what are we gonna do with all of
the of all the black people and and
that's where other racist white people
who are not quite as racist about a
slave owners but still pretty racist
said that well we should just ship them
all back to Africa even if they've never
lived there before they were born here
they've been here you know their
family's been here for hundreds of years
we just ship them back to Africa that
was that was Abraham Lincoln's solution
originally but and you know what here's
the thing the slave owners who made that
point that destroying that getting rid
of slavery will destroy the southern
economy you know something they were
right it would and it did destroy the
southern economy but so what okay your
economy shouldn't be based on slavery in
the first place and if it is then you
just need to deal with that it doesn't
matter that is not it's it's it's it
does not affect it one way or another we
we are not going to be even a little bit
swayed by this the simple fact of the
matter is slavery means you are
dehumanizing a person you are forcing
them to work for you like like a like
cattle you're treating them like farm
animals and that is never okay no matter
how much it helps the economy and it's
the same thing with babies you're
dehumanizing them you're treating them
like parasites are killing 60 million
human 60 million human beings over the
course of forty five years I don't care
how much it helps the economy it's wrong
but the second point is that actually it
does not help the economy because what
you have now is is in our culture the
sexual act has been severed you know or
the the life-giving aspect of a sexual
act has been severed from the sort of
pleasurable aspect
and because people know that they can be
reckless and they can just do whatever
they want
be irresponsible sexually and and they
know that push comes to shove they can
always just kill the baby even if they
don't call it killing a baby but they
know that and so that encourages people
to be sexually irresponsible and so then
you end up with even more unwanted
pregnancies STDs and all the rest of it
if abortion was illegal now in the short
term it would have it would create
challenges economically socially but
that's just something we got to deal
with long-term though I think long term
we'll we'll end up in a better spot
economically because people are gonna
have to start being responsible and
maybe you know don't have sex with
whoever you happen to meet on the street
corner maybe wait until you're in a
devoted and committed relationship
called a marriage before you have sex I
think people will be more and more
encouraged to do that and when you start
doing that it helps the culture it helps
everybody and it helps the economy
strong families are good for the economy
absolutely 100% all right so let's go to
emails this is from Matt Walsh Oh Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com as the email
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com is the
email address from Leonard Matt I like
your opinions on politics but you are
awful on Christianity that's probably
because you are not a Christian you are
an idol worshiper what you said on your
show yesterday was insane Christians can
never deny the authority of the Bible
when we do we have already lost the
argument yes every argument does go back
to the Bible and it should if someone
has the presupposition the Bible is
false they need to re-examine that
presupposition and until they do there's
no hope anyway they they will never be
convinced of anything anyway until they
accept the gospel message first everyone
knows that God is real even if they
don't admit it
that's why biblical arguments are always
valid you are horrible on theology and
you should really shut up about it
I won't be listening anymore but I
wanted to set you straight I wanted to
set you straight on this okay Leonard
well you apparently have run away with
your fingers in your ear so I guess
there's no point responding to you but I
will anyway let me try to help you out a
little bit because I suspect Leonard
that you probably have never persuaded
anyone of anything in your entire life
and I arrived at that assumption based
on how you have just framed your
argument here maybe you're having a bad
day or something so maybe this doesn't
represent how you normally approach
things I hope it doesn't because you
begin with a series of insults which
already shuts everything down you see
you see now I am going to overlook those
insults so that I can engage with you
but most of the time when you begin with
an insult whoever you're talking to is
not going to want to hear it and
especially if you're ostensibly
supposedly pretending that you're trying
to advance the gospel and get someone to
believe in the Bible well now they're
definitely not going to listen to you
and they shouldn't because of how
terribly you frame the argument why
should someone listen to you about the
Bible when you begin by insulting them
what why should they take you seriously
so so but you begin with insults then
you get into straw men distortions lies
confused thinking and it's just a mess
really all the way down the line and if
you're wondering why you have probably
never succeeded in convincing anyone of
anything ever in your life this is
probably the reason when you insult
people and lie about their positions you
just will not be able to connect so let
me try to respond piece by piece here
and by the way if you if you if you
didn't hear the show yesterday what he's
responding to is that I said that
Christians should not argue about
cultural and political issues with
non-christians by throwing Bible verses
at them if a person doesn't believe in
the Bible they will not find an appeal
to the Bible to be convincing therefore
it's better to find common ground with
them which is a basic essential aspect
of persuasion engage with them on that
level with logic reason and science
rather than just shouting verses from a
book that they think is mythological
that was the point that our friend
Leonard thinks is not only wrong but
insane now he thinks it's
seyn to try to find common ground with
your opponent and talk to them in
language and using terms and appealing
to authorities that they understand in
respect he thinks that that is actually
insane look he doesn't even understand
how how you could even think that that's
the right way to go about it
and he's not alone I got a lot of email
like this and most of it was equally as
insulting and you know I I got to say
honestly and I you know I've mentioned
the show plenty of times the the hate
mail angry emails I get that doesn't
surprise you right I mean anyone in this
line of work gets a lot of hate mail and
it's not a big deal doesn't doesn't you
know doesn't doesn't really hurt my
feelings I'm pretty impervious to it by
now but I really have to say that some
of the nastiest and most vicious emails
I get without a doubt are from
supposedly Bible believing Christians
out question you know the times in in my
in my writing or in my show when I have
tried to challenge Christians on
something or I have brought up a
theological topic that they found
challenging that is when I get the most
of vicious emails and what you just read
there is nothing compared to some of the
other stuff that I get although that is
that was pretty damn vicious now he
didn't cussed me out or anything like
that but you begin yeah I'm Christian
right my that my faith is the most
important thing to me so you begin by
just trying to spit all over that and
say well you're not even a Christian you
don't even believe this you're you are
you begin by pretending that you can
peer into my soul and just call me a
fraud about the thing that is most
important to me in my life now it
doesn't again it doesn't hurt my
feelings I'm used to it but that is such
a despicable and vicious and pointless
and stupid thing to do
and the only reason you do it is just to
make yourself feel better it's got
nothing to do with anything else it's
not you're not trying to spread the
gospel you're not this isn't about Jesus
this isn't about know this is just about
you making yourself feel better that's
all it's about so
you start by saying that I am denying
the authority of the Bible and thus
losing the argument already first of all
if we're not arguing about if we're not
arguing about the Bible then I don't see
how I lose the argument which is not
about the Bible when I don't even bring
up the Bible in the first place that
just makes no sense but just because you
fail to cite in authority doesn't mean
that you're denying the validity of that
Authority and by the way I I also said I
just said I referred to the Bible as an
authority and I guess I did that
yesterday too and I got a ton of email
about that says you called the Bible and
authority when you should have said the
authority oh my gosh
I mean can you what are you just sitting
there with like a notepad ready to go
any time he if he slips up with one
little word I'm gonna get him oh he said
and not the I got it whoa I'm writing an
email on this one can you just try to
listen and engage with the whole point
instead of trying to pick apart every
little thing that you can find so when
you fail to cite in authority doesn't
mean that you are denying the validity
of that Authority and I'm not saying
that in an argument with an atheist we
should begin by a pasta size and just to
find common ground I'm not saying that
we should begin the argument if we're
argue about abortion I'm not saying we
begin by saying just so you know it's at
the outset here I deny the authority of
the Bible no I absolutely agree with you
that that would be a bad way for a
Christian to begin an argument no I'm
saying that if you're going to make an
argument against abortion just point out
the biological fact that babies are
human people that is a biological fact
and then explain how killing them is
murder and if you're talking to someone
who already thinks that murder is wrong
which you definitely are
it's just that they think that isn't
murder so no you don't need to convince
them that murder is wrong they already
think that now you could say well they
have no real basis for thinking that
because they don't believe in the Bible
that may be the case but they still
think it so Sosa's on that common
around that common understanding that
they already have and then tried to
explain to them how abortion fits into
that category of murder if you can do
that you have convinced them it's
possible
you aren't denying the Bible you just
aren't bringing it up if your opponent
brings it up then yeah well now game is
on they brought it up when you're
arguing with someone if you want to
persuade them you generally want to
appeal to authorities they themselves
recognize and respect because if you
appeal to an authority they don't
recognize your argument will carry no
weight even though it should it still
won't it should I agree but it doesn't
it carries weight with me if you if you
know a biblical argument for me carries
weight it should carry weight for
everybody but it doesn't that's the
reality deal in reality not how you
think it should be but how it is so I
cannot stress that enough
just because you fail to cite a
particular authority that is not the
same thing as denying that Authority in
any argument there are probably millions
of authorities you could cite but you
don't have a million years to make the
argument so you pick one or two for
example if I was arguing with a fellow
Christian about say biology some
biological topic I would not cite
Richard Dawkins as an authority now
Dawkins is a world-renowned biologist he
certainly knows more about the subject
than you do or I do he is a he's a bee
as a scientist I think he's wrong about
a lot of very important things
especially when he ventures outside of
biology to get into religion and
philosophy that's when he goes way off
the rails but the point is because he is
known for his atheism I would not cite
him as an authority on a biological
topic even if he is in authority I
wouldn't do that because I know that the
other person in the discussion doesn't
consider him an authority and and and
doesn't like him and there's a lot of
baggage there and so bringing his name
up would only muddy the waters it would
turn into an argument about Richard
Dawkins instead of about the thing that
we're talking about whatever that
happens to be so I just wouldn't bring
name up it's not that I would be denying
his biological expertise I just I'm just
not bringing it up I just don't bring it
up we don't talk about that we talk
about this instead same for if I'm
arguing with a liberal on something and
they ask for a citation on a certain
point I say you know this or this thing
happened and they say oh yeah well when
did that happen show me an article okay
well I am NOT going to pull an article
from Fox News for this liberal even if
the article on Fox News is true I still
won't pull it not because I'm denying
that it's true but I know how that
person feels about Fox News and and so
they're not gonna be convinced by that
even if they should be they won't and my
goal here is to convince them I actually
want to persuade them the reason that I
get into scup maybe it's different for
some people but I get into discussions
and debates with people because I really
want them to understand and I really do
want to persuade them even if it doesn't
happen in the end that is what I want
that's the only reason I'm doing this
and so I'm gonna find an article
somewhere else that they would from an
authority that they will recognize that
will carry more weight with them I just
think that that is really logical
honestly and I guess I don't know how
else to put it like I don't even
understand how anyone could disagree
with anything I just said there it's
just it's the most this is basic level
persuasion so next you say that we can't
we can't help to convince people of
anything until we convince them about
the Bible that is just false you are you
are wrong um that tells me that you have
never succeeded in convincing anyone of
anything
which again goes back to the terrible
framing of your arguments I'm trying to
help you figure out maybe why you don't
convince anyone I have in my career
heard from many many many people who
told me that I did convince them on a
variety of topics and I'm not saying
this to brag I'm just there are people
who really think that you know you're
never going to convince anyone of
anything especially if they don't
believe in the Bible that's not true I
have
done it I have heard from those people
what were they all lying to me when they
come up and say oh you convinced me on
this they're all lying just last night
it's probably on video just last night a
woman got up I mean I couldn't have
scripted it any better although I didn't
script it a woman got up and said that a
year ago she was pro-abortion but today
she's pro-life because of the arguments
that I presented and that Ben Shapiro
presented so there you go she was
convinced and do you know what she was
convinced by she told me what it was she
didn't say oh I was convinced by her
theological arguments I was convinced by
the Bible she said I was convinced by
science
she said you brought up the scientific
arguments I looked at it I realized
there's no way around it and she was
convinced so you say it can't be done it
can I've done it okay a lot of people
have done it
ben shapiro does it all the time okay do
you know how many college students
atheist liberal conservative Christian
Jewish Muslim whoever genomic college
students have been convinced by ben
shapiro as arguments which are not based
on the bible and a witch and which are
not even coming from a Christian so he's
done it I've done it I hear from these
people they are nice enough to email me
and I really appreciate it when they do
because it encourages me it makes me
feel like this is all this is maybe this
isn't all just pointless actually or
what do you think do you think it's
better for that woman who net who now
she's now pro-life and she embraces life
and it's a beautiful thing do you think
is it better for her to remain
pro-abortion until she figures out her
theology is that what you think so all
the people that I have managed to
convince of the pro-life case are you
saying it's better for them to all be
pro-abortion really then you talk about
presuppositions and how people need to
re-examine them I agree they do need to
examine their presuppositions we all
need to examine our presuppositions we
need to be aware of them we need to
analyze them we need to know about them
but how do you get someone to do that
how do you get someone to re-examine
their prophet they're pretty supposition
do you get them to pre examine their
presuppositions by shout
at them examine your presuppositions I
suppose that would be one strategy but
it won't work
no you must get someone to examine their
presuppositions in a more nuanced and
subtle way
examining your presuppositions is a
difficult and scary thing and you won't
get anyone to do it by shoving it down
their throat it you just won't it will
not work so if you can for instance
succeed in changing someone's mind on
something like abortion a very
fundamental important issue like
abortion then the examination of
presuppositions will flow naturally from
that because they're gonna say wow I was
wrong about that what else was I wrong
about you know if somebody is if you
manage to convince someone of something
that means that that is someone who is
open-minded that they're willing to
listen that has intellectual integrity
and intellectual courage and so if they
have all those things which they must if
they were willing to listen to you and
be convinced then they are naturally
going to go from there and say what else
am I wrong about they're going to begin
to look at the flaws in their worldview
they will do this on their own without
you hectoring them about it
you sparked that process by not by
demanding it but by throwing a wrench
into their ideological framework by
convincing them on their own terms using
language they understand that they are
actually wrong about something to really
convince someone that they're wrong to
really do it that will inevitably be a
revolutionary moment for that person and
they will begin to re-examine things
automatically again I have been told by
people many times that they began the
process of becoming Christian have
became interested in Christianity not
because of any religious argument I made
or any viable verse I I quoted although
I have made many religious arguments and
I've quoted many many Bible verses but
what I've been told multiple times
is is that they decided that I was right
about other topics unconnected from
religion and then this made them think
we'll wait a second
what else is he right about you
introduce a little bit of light into
that darkness you get them thinking
re-examining you you make them
understand that they're actually wrong
about something and then everything else
could flow from there they begin to take
religion more seriously here's the thing
atheist secular people whether they're
avowed atheist or not and most people
aren't there just secular right they
don't think much about these things when
they see religious people who they know
are religious when they see them making
logical rational common-sense compelling
scientifically sound arguments that is
very it's a very compelling example for
them because it lets them know that it's
okay to be religious smart people can be
religious you don't have to put your
reason in your rationality your logic to
the side to be religious you don't have
to reject science to be religious I mean
these are things that a lot of secular
people think they think that I'm never
gonna be religious because in order to
be religious I have to essentially be a
an irrational [ __ ] who hates science
and think science is from the devil
that's what a lot of secular people
think and that's why they won't even
look at religion they're not even gonna
listen to you
because that's how they think of
religion but when they see that's not
the case it completely blows everything
apart from them for them and they
realize that oh wait a second you mean
you can have all of that really
logically the science and still be
religious whoa hold on a second and then
they start looking but if you reinforce
their view that religious people are
irrational science denying idiots
if you reinforce that by just screaming
Bible verses at them in topics where
it's not even directly related then all
you've
as you have just pushed them away from
religion and they'll probably never look
at it again congratulations you have not
only not convinced them but you have
maybe made it so that they will never be
convinced because you reinforced all of
the negative bad stereotypes and I mean
false stereotypes most of the time about
religion that they had in their mind so
finally you say that and this is why I
get so heated about this and so
passionate because I just you can be
logical rational reasonable you can love
science you can understand you could be
all of those things and religious I want
people to know that and I and I hate it
when these Christians are out there
essentially saying the opposite
basically saying no you know what the
atheists are right you got it you can't
do that you're not no logic and reason
that's idol worship you're you're a
Satanist science no these are a bunch of
they're all a bunch of liars it's a
conspiracy to take down the Bible what I
hear when I actually hear this from
Christians I get so angry because I you
you have no idea how much damage you're
doing do you realize how many souls you
have just consigned forever to
secularism finally you say that everyone
knows God is real I agree that knowledge
is innate natural law and that's why all
people everywhere in the world all
cultures have independently come up with
God concepts on their own but all
cultures around the world have not
independently on their own come to the
conclusion that the New Testament is
correct and Jesus is Lord why is that
because those truths are revealed they
are not innate and when I say an eighth
not an eighth I mean they're not
conclusions you just come to on your own
you don't you didn't you are a Christian
today because someone told you about it
someone convinced you to be Christian
that's why you're a Christian today if
nobody ever had you would not be a
Christian that's a fact people have to
be told these truths nobody knows these
truths without being told people can
figure out God or some kind of God
without being told but not a single
person
you know not a single person in North or
South America believed in Jesus until
people came here on boats and told them
convince them so conflating our innate
knowledge of God within an eighth
recognition of the validity of Holy
Scripture is absurd Jesus says go preach
the gospel to all nations because
because they won't know it unless you do
and we should and so we should we should
tell them we should preach it I'm not
saying we should but we should also be
prudent and wise and rational and
convincing persuasive and not a bunch of
unthinking self-righteous pretentious
insulting irrational bible thumpers
which is how we are portrayed and it's
actually how some of us really do behave
much to the embarrassment of the rest of
us the point is that somebody will
believe in the Bible if number one you
tell them about it and number two you
give them reasons to believe it you
can't just say here's the Bible believe
it you even that's not going to work you
have to give them reasons and there are
good reasons but the point is that's a
case you have to make and you and you do
have to make it and you can't appeal to
the Bible until you have made that case
and the other person has been convinced
of it so if that case has not been made
and they have not been convinced of it
your appeals to Authority even though it
is valid Authority will fall on death
each deaf ears will have no impact at
all and that's just the reality listen
to have some humility listen to what
non-religious atheist secular
non-christian people tell you every
single one of them without exception
will tell you that when you just throw
Bible verses at them and you have
there's no logic there's no reason
there's no science or anything in your
argument just throw Bible verses they
just tuned you out and it doesn't
convince them every single one of them
will tell you that listen
to them instead of sitting there and
saying no you know what I know more
about what's happening in their mind
than they do that is so unbelievably
arrogant and who do you think you are
what do you think you're God you you you
they're they're telling you what they
find convincing yours like no you know I
know what you find you you don't know
what you find convincing I'll tell you
when you find convincing and then you
wonder why they shut you down and shut
you out they should alright let's see
her I spent all the time at one email so
I guess that kind of uh I see I'm trying
to get one more one more email all right
this was from brian says oh semi
benevolent highly corrupt theocratic
future dictator may you live forever
thankless finally someone addresses me
how I should be addressed during the
required listening to your show from
yesterday I came up with a bit of a
different perspective to the idea of
trying to argue with an English speaker
in Chinese or literally throwing the
Bible at someone who does not hold it as
an authority besides in some cases
there's no exact language but as the
first and most life-affirming collection
of writings ever created calling the
ancient Jews to be the first people not
to build some God and sacrifice children
to it the clarity is in the context I'll
not go down that rabbit hole the rabbit
trail that killing your children has
usually been the norm for those not in
covenant to God and that in abortion
culture we're simply seeing those who
reject God returning to the carnal
natural desires of the flesh back to my
point that was a good point
imagine you meet a screechie socialist
loving high school teacher you know the
type
if a student has anything pro-america to
say they get shouted down you want to
argue with this person that capitalism
is a good thing would you use the
Constitution as an authority with with
with them would you use the Magna Carta
or the Federalist and anti-federalist
papers to convince them as a teacher
there's some chance that they have read
those documents even if this teacher
hasn't read them they have expressly
dismissed these writings and coming to
their socialist conclusions while living
in the United States they prefer the
shoddily written green new deal over the
Bill of Rights how are you going to
convince them of anything worth thinking
the difference with the atheist is that
if you show them some respect you have
some chance of a step in your direction
you also need to pick your battles and
know when you're dealing with a pig
just wants to roll around in the mud
it's the same way that you would not be
able to use the Koran or Hindu Buddhist
scientologists or any other religions
writings with me because I have
dismissed them the difference is I don't
dismiss the people who believe those
things what do you think it is my hope
that the above fawning gesticulation
will ensure my high ranking position
when you come to power or at the least
the keeping of my head Brian well I
asked for that last point I'm afraid I
cannot promise you that because you did
call me semi benevolent and I be
interested to find out where you think
the semi comes from and so it is for
that comment that you will probably have
to pay with your life but until that
point I'll address your email and I'll
time to get your affairs in order before
you're executed yeah I think well I
agree with much of what you're saying
here and you know the the example you
give of the the socialist loving high
school teacher well there's another
example right now this is a political
conversation so there are many
authorities on you know on on on these
issues that normally you would use but
you wouldn't be able to use with this
person because they don't accept those
authorities and it's just not going to
carry any weight with them and so yeah
it makes it it makes it more difficult
but you see that's the whole art of
persuasion and of argumentation that you
you've just you got to figure out you
got to understand the other person
you'll figure out where they're coming
from where they're beginning and yeah
the more common ground you share with
them the easier it's gonna be to
convince them it's very difficult if you
have almost no common ground it's gonna
be really difficult to to launch a
campaign of persuasion from there it can
be done it's just more difficult but you
do have to go through this process so I
mean just we were talking yesterday at
dinner someone said you know what do you
do and when talking about abortion what
do you do with someone who does admit
that abortion is murder but doesn't care
how do you convince them well yeah
that's a that's a really difficult now
here's an example here's someone now
most people you talk to you they will
share the presupposition that a murder
is wrong they but they will just try to
claim that abortion doesn't fall into
that category so then all you have to do
is convince them but it does fall into a
category it's not easy to do but it's
easier than this where this person
doesn't even think that murder is wrong
and so how do you start there what
common ground can you find with this
person well the point is you got to find
something because if you can't find
anything well then there's nothing you
can save them but it does become
difficult yet it doesn't you know
doesn't relieve you of the duty of
having you do it and and the point is
yeah with something like abortion well
look I mean the whole argument against
abortion basically is that it's murder
so that's the argument so if they don't
share that presupposition then that is a
case where you probably can't move
forward in the conversation and until
you they share that presupposition but
the point is so now you have to argue
for that you you have to make your case
for that you have to try to explain to
them that murder is wrong you can't just
continue in the discussion as regardless
of the fact that they don't agree with
you on that point and up you cannot just
continue in the discussion and keep
appealing to this idea that murder is
wrong with a person who doesn't share
that point of view you can't go anywhere
you have to first convince them of that
so that you can then appeal to it
convince them first that oh no murder is
definitely wrong here's why if they go
okay yeah I see what you're saying now
you could go forward the job isn't done
yet now you have to go and figure out
well here's abortion here's how that
fits into that category of wrong things
which we call murder alright we'll leave
it there I guess I'll save the rest of
the emails for next time and thank you
all for listening Godspeed today on the
Ben Shapiro show Facebook looks to the
government for help censoring viewpoints
and it gets ugly that's today on the
bench Shapiro show